we always have a Kevin Frazier here yeah
but I don't think he's missing us not
even one iota because I yes soaring with
the Angels why are you working keV guys
once again I have scored a seat on the
most exclusive flight in the air I'm
flying in Emporia Secret Angels to Paris
I'm gonna show you what happens when the
doors close on this flight things get
crazy is what it's like to travel with
angels not as easy as you think
[Music]
who's the prankster on this plane it's
Adriana Lima
what are you doing
[Music]
I can't go to sleep with her around
[Music]
do not mess with me
I don't want to take it now please
return to your seat
this year's Victoria's Secret Show is
the biggest ever here's the breakdown 51
models all traveling first class on a
jet provided by Mark Cuban with five
security guards Lady Gaga the weekend
and Bruno Mars will perform and then
there's the Fantasy Bra with thousands
of gemstones three million dollars
wearing it on the runway that honor goes
to Jasmine tooks I been home for three
hours I could not move it all took that
cold and then bent the brown top of it
also on board
kendall Jenner and Bella Hadid who hung
out together on the plane meanwhile
Bella's sister Gigi also walking in the
show but she missed the flight as for me
this trip was nothing short of heavenly
is one of their other things I have to
do I have to do Adriana's nails
[Music]